allora ragazzi ci siamo italianizzati un
po di più oggi col pedalò siamo su un
lago e siamo sul lago che dà sul monte
fuji che è quello che vedete lì e mi
sento molto marco toni in questo video
ciao marco ti salutiamo e siamo una
coppia romanticismo amicissima decisione
se fare una cosa che non dovrei fare ma
la faccio lo stesso attacco selvi stick
al telefono e provo a registrarmi mentre
etico dal cigno poi passiamo a servizi
per amici miei
sopra utilizzare un attrezzo utilizzato
da molte mamme zero serve per questa
cosa aspetta
eccolo ragazzi abbiamo il cigno
lo abbiamo chiamato antonio suo figlio
siamo su un pedalò cigno quella del
monte fuji quello già anche pedala a me
e cadevo facevo 8 milioni di views ma è
meglio non cadere in questo caso
preferisco non parla allora per fare
questa cosa stiamo usando un self
istinct della madonna e stiamo cercando
di fare la foto di your name e adesso
vediamo se riusciamo a fare questa cosa
giovanni clip che news take pictures of
us induction over quasi cinese
[Musica]
come si mettono le prese italiane dentro
le spine giapponesi vai jam adattatore
multinazionalità siccome però il latore
moti delle nazionalità soltanto due
buche non tre come quelli italiani
dobbiamo mettere una riduzione inglese
che però all'adattatore tedesco qui
dobbiamo mettere un multi tab tedesco e
quindi dobbiamo mettere poi una
riduzione italiana per poi poterci
finalmente mettere la ciabatta e adesso
sapete che con gusto e l'arma dei power
rangers prego prego signor prego signor
max adesso tu vuoi dirmi che non ci
stava
in questo piatto quello no non ci stava
quindi l'hanno messo l'indicatore
arigatò casa e dame stoffa da dina no no
ragazzi fate io aspetto il mio turno ho
trovato uno schermo lcd che è uno
specchio in tutto e per tutto solo che
fa le cose costa 5 mila euro più o meno
tanti che non arrivino creature strane
dalla foresta perché ci sono insetti un
po particolare
però per il resto è figo ragazzi stiamo
andando alla pagoda dalla quale si vede
poi il monte fuji per bene e ci sono 400
scalini da fare
io so già questo era il primo sono
stanco già adesso basta già basta
veramente basta non ce la fanno cimatti
finanziano ce la faccio più massimo
relativa bassa basta abbiamo fatto jean
dov'è il monte fuji
e dov'è il monte bianco
allora io io io non so cosa dire
comunque non so non dico niente no vabbè
ma che bobo ragazzi io vi giuro
voi non potete capire quanto è calda
questa rho e in questa roba è l'inferno
e l'inferno in giappone scelto kamakura
come meta turistica perché c'è la
spiaggia e ci saremmo rilassati un po
sotto il sole si contenta gianni
tantissimo
beh va beh ragazzi almeno non c'era
vento
no ma non bere il caffè il giappone
ragazzi è tutto bellissimo e vi dirò di
più se non hai voglia di fare l'albero
di natale a natale lo fai adesso a
maggio che va bene lo stesso tanto
chissenefrega dai già ambieni dai gianni
divertente via inizio iniqua
multiplayers gioco vieni vieni non il
signore vieni tu dai ma lo fa il signore
dai ma ma ma cosa devo fare qua
come la quale l'anno
aderito
siamo davanti al monumento di hiroshima
che un rudere che rimasti piedi dopo la
bomba atomica è questo ma perché perché
come ragazzi facciamola cagata di
provare un ristorante italiano allora
pranzo fisso e poi abbiamo un corso di
cena un corso di prefisso è cosa cosa
vuol dire un call cos'è insegnerà a
mettere il piu 39 ragazzi vicino al mio
letto c'è questa tenda che come la
finestra che avrebbe aveva un po
ridicola che potevano anche non metterla
ma se tu apri la finestra sotto c'è un
corridoio purissimo e orribile sola non
dormirò mai
no no no gas ore da
[Musica]
è molto carina quest'isola perché ci
sono le persone le persone le persone
water water faq normali
magari però non leghiamo i domini ecco a
posto vuole fare un po di tomino ciao
ragazzi sono lorenzo sono pago già ma
chi sta riprendendo oggi una stanza
d'albergo hh a kamakura kamakura ha una
particolarità ve la faccio vedere
venite ma ci sono due porte ce n'è una
scena un'altra però c'è una
particolarità adesso vi faccio vedere la
stanza è divisa in due stanze questa è
la nostra doveva tessera questa è
completamente un'altra stanza 15 possa
esser altre persone
oggi entriamo nella nostra stanza di
facile come questa è la sua stanza
abbiamo ben un letto due letti ma non
solo
abbiamo ben tre letti e quattro eletti e
siamo in due
ma chi se ne frega perché la chicca
arriva adesso a parte il fatto che la
stanza è un corridoio ma venite qua
sempre state attenzione
noterete un passaggio sottilissimo tra
una stanza e l'altra che semplicemente
divisone un armadio dove nessun essere
umano normalmente potrebbe mai passarci
perché davvero poco poco poco spazioso
lo spiraglio nessun essere umano
tranne io se tutto va bene entrano
nell'altra stanza e la sbloccherò ci
passo veramente a stento
mi passa tutto tranne il culo attenzione
che quella tessera ragazzi non senza
però fare ei abbiamo quattro letti in
più adesso che sappiamo fare di più
un bacio ci vediamo al prossimo episodio
di entriamo nelle camere degli altri
casi ciao ragazzi è così che si
registrano i video passato un sacco di
tempo dall'ultima volta che ho
registrato un video ogni volta che
l'inizio a registrare dopo tanto tempo è
molto strano mi sembra di non averlo mai
fatto prima
quindi wow sarà aggiunge poi a fare un
viaggio un po particolare perché c'ero
già stato due volte entrambe le volte ci
sono stato tre settimane però quelle
volte li ero stato solo a tokyo o una
volta a kyoto però solo in una città
sono stato praticamente invece stavolta
sono andato in giro per tutto il
giappone o comunque per un sacco di
location perché volevo vedere un po
com'era il giappone in generale questo
viaggio è stato è stato il più bello
della mia vita secondo me non potrà mai
essere battuto po staccato completamente
la testa da youtube non guardavano a chi
video come stavano andando dove ho
staccato completamente la testa da
youtube da tutto il mondo del del blog
ed è proprio per questo motivo che avete
visto quasi tutte storie in questo video
e poche registrazioni fatte gola
videocamera proprio perché ho voluto
vivermi il giappone senza la distrazione
della videocamera e ha funzionato perché
me lo sono veramente vissuto al cento
per cento quindi questo avete visto era
veramente poco di quello che in realtà è
stato il viaggio però ragazzi che video
vi sia piaciuto perdonatevi ancora se
erano instagram stormire auto messaggio
se erano gli stack al sori invece che un
video girato con la fotocamera furto in
grazia gianandrea per essere stato un
grande compagno di viaggio io concluso
cui video ragazzi come se lasciato un
momento mi piace anche al rifiuto da
descrizione se non si dovesse
iscrivetevi era come sempre ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo
beh ragazzi
qualcuno mi ha detto che sta per uscire
super meat boy 2
[Musica]